isaacoros on the floor for the Cavs
Mitchell in tour Caruso off to a coral a
40 fires a three and knocks it down yeah
Donovan got move it jammed up on the
drop
s it back to Mitchell Mitchell free to
shoot finds Osmond out of the has it
nice job nice little top pass there by
Donovan Mitchell Donovan makes a nice
move over the top of the Kobe's head
there with the basketball kicks it to
the corner as the defense collapses so
difficult to deal with Isaac so strong
Mitchell pulls up he knocks it down boy
I tell you those are his shots talk to
him before the before the game it's a 31
possession
as Mitchell appeals to Allen Allen
floats over to roses and gets it to go
yes sir need more of that from Jared
Allen keep the boots off of that
backboard good job
Mitchell lines of a three tiger knocks
it down it's okay just keep Let it Fly
some energy here if they're going to go
into halftime going to look at some film
and make some adjustments but make some
plays right now there you go nice
Mitchell now has 10 points out of the
corner dumps off to Osmond Osmond breaks
to the foul line
now Mitchell Mitchell across the lane oh
what a shot by a mission
Donovan has his head up
Jake's on Caruso for a long time
Mitchell has a chance for the four-point
play there's a flicker that flame spot a
bite that's what we need he's just
picking up the aggressiveness put some
Caruso old skates bucket
once again
bottom Cavs are shooting 40 percent the
Bulls 54. they told down the alley
finger rolls and scores now has 19.
going to the basket deep into the clock
a lot of times
get that shot blocked
Mitchell grinds his way inside floats
and score yeah he's gonna have to just
pull the load tonight he is a low big
strong
very very you know because you're trying
to get away from him because he's really
strong and he's coming right at you
match over the basket gets the roll he
created more of that space Donovan
Mitchell is heating up here in this
third quarter
Mitchell works on Caruso got bumped by
Williams puts it up and at home
has a chance for three Russo can't do
anything with him help is late but
there's the foul nice job
China Chicago it almost sense that Billy
Donovan you want him taking that shot
not bad defensive stand by the Cavs
Mitchell crossed over his van and Levine
as Donovan Mitchell continues to cook
here in the third okay either way the
Cavs won't argue we'll take it
Mitchell
Ken funner he's got it Mitchell gets
bound
one quarter and he is absolutely put the
Cavs on his back and they are roaring
back can you see the foul right there on
the elbow
Cavaliers are right back within striking
difference distance 10 point ball game
right now this is great great news for
Cavaliers fans they found a a recipe
wrong rebound as he darts into the
basketball Mitchell with his head up
relays the love love for three
knocks it down nice job by the Cavaliers
they can pass that basketball
Mitchell draws a double Osmond's wide
open he's got it love it straight
himself is played by Donovan recognize
the Double T
Levert picked up by Williams goes to
Mitchell Mitchell penetrate lays it up a
hand
that Mitchell's show continues Mitchell
has already played 37 big minutes
here tonight just under eight to go
Mitchell pulls up it doesn't matter
but the Cavaliers Donovan Mitchell he's
everywhere taking this personally he is
going after these moves that's all right
around corrosive in the back and lays it
up an end oh what a gorgeous move by
Mitchell who now has 48.'s got to keep
putting the heat on him
Mitchell off to love love wide open for
a three he's got it perfect nice job
Kevin Love winning the games you're
supposed to win and then battling with
those other teams DeMar DeRozan now has
35 points Mitchell inside his floater
doesn't go he gets it back hooks it up
and in Donovan Mitchell has 50 points
here tonight
just couldn't quite get enough behind it
the rosie steps up but DeRozan does not
box out
the Bulls have committed 27 fouls and
eventually the Allen Allen dunks and a
foul called Jared Allen had a chance for
three this man comes over to help
everybody's coming over to help oh
Donovan Mitchell Jared very smart taking
advantage of that opening stepping into
it fair enough he has played 42 minutes
has Donovan Mitchell zigzags inside
floats it up and floats it in 52 now for
Mitchell my goodness Donovan Mitchell
Mitchell in toward the rose and knocked
him down finds Levert Levert for three
then he knocks it down that is a huge
bucket Levert has been just one for nine
from the field two possession game get a
good shot quality shot a lot of time
left no Panic H steam has two timeouts
remaining Mitchell
knocks it down [ __ ] it we didn't know
what we were gonna get you get a big
dream that puts us right back in the
little Mitchell where else to the back
it puts it up Allen with a good follow
out to Osmond back to Levert Around the
Horn to love Mitchell wants it good play
to keep that ball in bounds Mitchell
close to Allen Allen done
we're almost to foul there I thought it
was a foul and one didn't get that call
let's see it looks like he got all right
all right good job by the Cavs though it
just took a lot of time
you're hoping he misses one of these
if he misses it tip it out and hopefully
one of our guys catches it
game one and shot yeah enough time to do
that with four seconds here we go
he missed it
[Applause]
Donovan Mitchell
we're tied with three seconds to go
terrific anticipation and how does he
get there in among a handful of the
Bulls
what a night what a night for Donovan
Mitchell all wheel all wheel he wanted
that basket so bad he was not going to
be denied it's all effort and just will
by Donovan Mitchell
[Applause]
Mitchell pulls up
oh my goodness young man get you off
your feet here for just 30 seconds only
bucket so it does far in overtime right
here Donovan Memphis man he is
absolutely wearing that net out
to the pain off into Sumo he left that
short rebounded by LeVert here's
Mitchell he just blew right past Levine
Mitchell to the basket
[Applause]
Donovan Mitchell show there goes that
man number 45.
[Applause]
Mitchell wants it he gets it Mitchell
steps back down
unbelievable watching this my goodness
I mean
Mitchell for three oh unbelievable
[Applause]
I don't know what else to say
I don't I got nothing else to say this
is unbelievable
gas by nine now it's Mitchell he gets
fouled
Insurance generally
the Bulls
foot Mitchell on the line and a grin
escapes the face
of number 45.
he knows precisely what he's done
tonight and that's what this Cavalier
team on his back
and carry it to Victory Mitchell looks
for 70.
[Music]
wow a sight to behold I've never thought
I would witness something like this
someone's going 70 points
under these circumstances this is just
unbelievable he can't stop smiling Brad
fantastic basketball
wow and ear to ear grin on that line and
there it is
wow you don't need to contain yourself
young man you earned every bit of it
here tonight what a victory what a
performance
Donovan Mitchell in his first season in
Cavalier wine and gold in front of this
crowd here in downtown Cleveland
goes for 71 points as the Cavs Roar from
behind and take out the Bulls by the
final of 145.
134 again and electrifying a
breathtaking a dazzling a phenomenal
performance
amount of words Brad
I mean great effort by the Cavaliers as
well to support him Jared Allen made
some huge plays Jenny Osmond made some
big shots aggressive defense by Neto
guys came in and did a great job Kevin
Love taking charges so they supported
him they gave that tiger his head and he
went to work and wore out the Bulls an
all-time great performance in NBA
history
Donovan Mitchell played 50 minutes
tonight
go along with those 71 points he dished
out it 11 assists grabbed eight rebounds
Serena is waiting to get in there to
have a word with the man of the hour who
took Center Stage got full marks here
tonight
[Music]
a historic
signature performance
here in downtown Cleveland
as Donovan Mitchell goes for 71 the High
game in the NBA this season the first
70-point game in the NBA since 2017.
this man was magic here tonight he did
it absolutely all in that second half
had a decent first half kind of kept to
somewhat in it which you know struggled
everywhere else but my goodness
fantastic and with that let's go to
Serena thanks John Donovan Mitchell the
new franchise record 71 points
thank you
MVP
MVP
MVP MVP
[Applause]